there are a bunch of studies that show
that music can actually change your mood
and help you adapt to stress and people
are like neuroscisors are working
together to create playlists that can
either help increase your attention and
focus or put you in a better mood we saw
that in the Olympics with it the guys
coming out you know the swimmers were
coming out and everybody had their
little headphones on you know and you
wouldn't what are they listening to I
Want To Know music I hate to interrupt
can we uh can we just sing another song
I can't get that damn song out my head
now
one thing to say though about music is
that it does um impact the subcortical
evolutionarily older parts of your brain
like the basal ganglion the emotional
scent that are below the cortex and
that's why for example with Alzheimer's
when they're having dementia and like
the sort of decreased um cortex if you
play music for them it can incorate them
because it's these more subcortical
deeper I've heard about that one yeah
it's pretty cool